[Music]
hello there Merry Christmas Happy New
Year January once known as the slowest
month for gaming has suddenly become one
of the best here's a bunch of new games
coming in January from AAA Masterpiece
to freet to-play beauty and some awful
dad jokes at the end of the video just
for you let's do
this it's finally time for Tekken to
return and reclaim its Crown as the best
fighting game on the market I am
slightly biased yes Tekken 8 arrives
with the latest iron tournament a long
running story which invites the best
fighters from all over the globe to take
part in grueling combat over the years
multiple narratives have evolved with
the key battle between the Mishima Clan
who happen to have a devil Gene waiting
inside them to cause Havoc I'll link a
story video if you'd like 20 years
summed up quickly basically lots of
Fathers and Sons throwing each other
from the top of very high Cliffs
gameplay-wise just like Mortal Kombat
and Street Fighter combos play a key
part in brawls with blocking an ever
important element two and this is where
Tekken changes things first we have
sidest stepping to bring 2D Fighters
into the 3D World circumventing those
characters who are great at blocking and
the rage system returns with a little
reworking to become a heat system which
now rewards aggressive players rather
than those people who constantly back up
and play defensively Tekken looks more
cinematic than ever and with 32
confirmed playable characters right away
there's a lot to master and as the name
suggests Tekken 8 is the 11th game in
the series coming to PS5 Xbox series and
PC on January
26th The Last of Us Part Two is back
again 4 years later this time it's the
remastered version for the PS5 right
away something you should know is that
if you already own the PS4 version
you'll be able to upgrade to the PS5
remastered version for only $10 we're
still waiting to know the conversion
rate for other countries so double check
your region to be safe The Last of Us
Part Two brings back Joel and Deli and
continues their fight for survival in a
world infested with zombie like
creatures set in third person with
stealth sections exploration and pretty
competent combat too as well as
everything from the original part two
there are tons of extras worth looking
at first a dedicated guitar mode because
we all love that section so much and
check out this a Rog likee mode is
included dedicated solely to the combat
if the story wasn't really for you we be
able to play through some of the cut
content from the game Lost Levels with
commentary from the devs who made them
if you've never played The Last of Us
Part Two you must and if you're like me
and you struggled with the story first
time around maybe it's time to give it
another go four years later or you could
skip it and play golf instead I guess
the Last of Us Part Two remastered is a
PlayStation 5 exclusive releasing on
January
19th yet another returning franchise is
here Prince of Persia the Lost Crown a
turn to the Sid scrolling style but with
the combat finesse of more modern games
put simply imagine the Rayman games
crossed with Hades traversal looks fluid
packed with air dashes and slide jumps
and the combat appears to have elements
of hack and slash with later enemies
needing more thought to defeat the story
centers around sagon one of Persia's
Elite Warriors who alongside his crew is
sent to rescue the Prince of Persia as
we track him we must battle through
thousands of enemies Crossing many
biomes and solving puzzles along the way
a Metroid Vania structure is used to
interconnect all the stages allowing for
backtracking to find shortcuts and
previously unavailable upgrades
retailing at $50 50 and 45 quid here in
the UK Prince of Persia the Lost Crown
could be exactly what this series needs
January 18th on Playstation Xbox and
PC it was just over a month since the
last Yakuza game released yet here's
another one to take over your life yet
again like a dragon infinite wealth the
Japanese focused RPG takes its first
steps overseas visiting Hawaii we play
as Ichiban Kasa who's looking for his
mother in Hawaii and Kazuma KIU is here
writing a bucket list because kyu's days
are numbered and he plans to tie a few
loose ends before his final days but
rest assured all the goofy activities
that this series is known for is here
expect the Yakuza storyline to return
and in surmountable odds for our Duo to
fight through that said you should know
that combat is turn-based each player
has a circle of operation to plan and
perform an attack but some characters
can also fight in real time when they
break out of that mode it's weird this
series is renowned for being weird in a
good way like a dragon infinite wealth
drops on the PlayStations the Xboxes and
the PC on January
26th oky dokie let's do some free stuff
first an update from all the things you
may have missed in December fortnite
released a music mode which Harps back
to Guitar Hero and it's totally free
they also released Lego Lego fortnite
which is essentially Lego Minecraft
again totally free those of you with God
of War Ragnarok should check out the
free DLC Valhalla which lets Kratos
fight through his past and recalls the
older God of War games it's amazing now
have you seen hawed a free toplay
extraction shooter with this gorgeous
art style originally this was planned to
release in 2023 on PC and console well
the PC version arrived but a little more
work is needed for the console version
which is now expected to arrive very
early in 2024 essentially 30 players
join the game in groups of three and
then fight their way into ancient tombs
to solve puzzles and une Earth Treasures
it's then a simple run to pick up that
loot and get to the extraction point of
course things don't always go to plan
because the other treasure hunting
Renegades are informed when the treasure
room is opened and then they track you
instead it's like a friendlier version
of the dark Zone from the division
there's some really impressive free
flowing traversal using grapples and
these weird surfboard style getaway
vehicles which all add up to frantic
chases to the end zone hawked console
release date is due any second now I
will pin it in the comments below as
soon as I know if you don't want to wait
the PC version is out right
now every year a new free-to-play
pinball game arrives this year it's
pinball M you know the premise fire a
metal ball around a table and keep it
from falling in the gutter but this time
all the tables are horror themed the way
the game monetizes is via selling more
tables your favorite franchises in
pinball fashion there are free tables
like the Wrath of the Elder gods and
other tables rotate in and out of free
to play Pinball m is out right now on
Playstation Xbox and PC virtual reality
users you can download a game called
epic roller coasters there are four
roller coaster tracks to experience
which is a pretty good Showcase of The
Sensational speed of VR then on top of
that there is a racing mode for people
who want even more speed in their eye
holes and then there is a shooter mode
where Riders are given targets to hit
whilst trying not to throw up on a
roller coaster the D Jurassic Park
coaster is what I'm going to play over
Christmas epic roller coasters is out
right now for free on psvr 2 pcvr and
there's a mobile version
too objection did you ever play the Ace
Attorney games well those DS games have
been collected and remastered for last
gen consoles and PC we joined rookie
attorney Apollo Justice and his
legendary Mentor Phoenix Wright and
sleuth our way through three games or 14
episodes of Apollo Justice Ace Attorney
Phoenix Wright Ace Attorney Dual
Destinies and Phoenix Wright Ace
Attorney Spirit of Justice with tons of
little extras like clothing music and
animations it's a chance for fans to
relive the courtroom drama and a great
way to preserve games in 2024 January
24th on PS4 Xbox One and PC and of
course the switch let's give a little
love to VR this year with Bullet Storm
VR a brutal first-person shooter in
which we play as a space mercenary and
annihilate every mutated alien in sight
as this is a VR game we can dual wield
weapons like a bass and a new energy
blade has been made just for this mode
so we can literally carve through
enemies originally intended to be
released in December the decision was
made to push this back to January 18th
on psvr 2 meta Quest and steam
VR oky doie I've prattled on for long
enough I owe you some dad jokes my
favorite teacher at school was called
Miss
Turtle because she taught us well get it
taught us taught us she taught us well
it doesn't matter taught us well yeah
these jokes work better when I don't
explain them yeah sorry I asked my dad
how much does a chimney cost he said
nothing it's on the
house thank you thank you very much okay
I've got one more in me I was once
locked in a small room with Santa now
now I'm
claustrophobic thank you very much have
a brilliant 2024 I'm Adam you're awesome
I'll see you next
time